Lethal Weapon is like nah man it's I saw
Mel Gibson and Roger Murtaugh he's so
good at that character that is him
I would see Roger Murtaugh no matter
what role that is even a witness when he
cracked the saw is woody when he when he
comes back together later on in his life
and he's trying to do good again and he
does with his angels in the outfield and
saw actually take place at the same time
hey guys I am Gregory Angelo Alba my
name is John John is here today with me
to watch the trailer for the [ __ ] show
that's right
[ __ ] show now Fox I just saw your
trailer for The Exorcist that was pretty
cool but I I'm letting you know right up
front that I've already like not
accepting of this little idea Lethal
Weapon show oh my god this is a sore
spot for you this is a very sore spot
you know I've been like actively coming
up with a lethal weapon five this time
it's personal this time it's yeah mine's
really personal I know yeah I know it's
personal between you is this Fox two
highly focuses on Rene Russo station I
just don't think it's like what happened
with rush hour Hey that shit's getting
canned
I didn't even know that show aired yeah
who the [ __ ] cares about it you know why
you want it because rush hour wasn't
about the amazing you know [ __ ]
masterpiece for the film it was that
stories laser it works so well because
of Chris Tucker and Jackie Chan yes I
what you say about the point of really
brave yeah it's it's not so much about
like doing the story again it's about
those about those characters those
actors this place yeah
those actors their chemistry together
it's that's what makes them like awesome
films Lethal Weapon I don't care like
what you guys thought of part three and
four you thought they were [ __ ] they've
still got great actor unit they have
dynamic chemistry there's just no way
you can replace these guys I'm sorry I'm
ready really against this whole idea I
think they should still do Lethal Weapon
5 and I should pitch the screenplay yeah
I'm right there with you there are
certain things are you're not gonna do
it the right way I want to get crossover
with the Fast and Furious franchise yeah
yeah Sega remaking the Fast and Furious
recasting Mel Gibson and Fast and
Furious it worked
yeah be perfect that's what you should
have done average machete killed
original man
himself that's in my Mad Max Furious
movies are these fairness in is you get
Mel Gibson to come back as the real max
and he's [ __ ] up now is that those
human really a desert of PTSD and there
you go and the new max in part nine have
you helped them yeah you just cheese
with you that was brilliant
yeah pay us thank you you see let's
watch this awesome trailer I think Dino
ancestors are gonna bad experience ain't
it works perfectly
do me a favor
don't shoot together
Martin Riggs we're gonna make a great
team is the Theo a day dead on arrival
does it mean something different here no
I just want to make sure there's no one
home we had to give Jimmy this dude is
in the class by himself who is it
nobody is high for grades I'm sure
you've heard a lot about oh we have
dinner would you like to come in no you
can't get stuff you got to come on no I
mean it does smell good so do you have a
taste learning I do not such a Mary
Oh No if you ask me to - not anymore she
passed away oh sorry my dumbass it's
beautiful good game something to live
for
whoa really I need you to be honest with
me do you think race is dangerous Darry
what I didn't kill him
be safe up there always
what the hell did this guy do the
question of my guy leg so we probably
and then they pulled a gun on yes and he
pulled the gun try to be better Joey you
fifty years old more time still only a
detective I like solving cases not
kissing acid
well I liked it for once
they made a joke about an actor having
to be like older than they actually are
or his damon wayans really
ha
that was the most heartbreaking
oh my god for you I feel bad too just I
don't know it as well what have you done
you've turned lethal weapon into that
Fox comedy yeah
like the yeah rhythm was just off Riggs
seems like a psycho like Riggs is a
psychopath and lethal weapon one
he's a psycho please don't [ __ ] Mel
Gibson sir he's charming and sexy and
all that and likable this Riggs I'm like
these guys just seems like he's you know
a real sociopathic I'm a guy your action
hero moments and and then the back and
forth between Murtagh and Damon Wayans
just it's it's my wife and kids meet a
psychopath that's what it is wants to be
like 21 Jump Street or one of those
movies it's like oh we got big action
but it's also like banter comedy yeah
these guys don't belong together I know
it's like a traditional buddy cop
formula but it seems really wacky it
seems formulaic it seems generic there's
there's really trying hard to make it
cooler make it funny it's just Damon
Wayans it's like I'm not saying like you
gotta be [ __ ] Danny Glover yeah just
don't be Damon Wayans playing a cop
yeah you at least at Channel Danny
Glover gotta play a character right now
man at least the guys playing Warner
eggs seems like he's trying something
new yeah I know he's not doing like
she's not trying to be Mel Gibson but
same time I'm like something about you I
just don't like oh yeah rub me the wrong
way
it's like he's too cool and he hasn't
earned it it's like too cool it feels to
me it's really hard like if you have two
beloved characters and you walk one guy
in who you know again it's like you're
not really channeling the spirit and
then you walk another guy who's like I
don't know you very well and then to mix
two big change and try to fill the shoes
of that performance Danny Glover
it'll be very happy cover it now channel
the spirit a there's no there's no
[ __ ] like storyline to hear that I'm
like intrigued by at all yeah I know
that's like toys just watch like random
cop investigations all the time like
there was a whole [ __ ] like story
about Mel Gibson's dead wife there's a
lot [ __ ] going on and in the personal
lives of these characters and that was
the thing there was also they were also
r-rated they were dark they got more
comedic as they yes when the first one
was really dark there's humor didn't
seem like it was stopping to be a comedy
where is this one yeah I was like it
wants to be an action comedy sometimes
than like a gritty show other times than
like a fierce melodrama no that's that
was the problem that people have with a
scripted Lethal Weapon 4 okay now this
is just a comedy you know like this is
definitely an action comedy I personally
liked it because I loved the characters
yeah but it is definitely like the
writing is a comedy as opposed to lethal
weapon one and a lot of part two
excluding Joe Pesci's character the
funniness just comes out of the natural
parts of the characters yeah you know on
their what on an omission and
investigative mission that is intrigue
there's nothing here where I'm like
there's no investigation happening yeah
I was like I wanna [ __ ] find like
Jessica Jones with the trailers about
kilgrave and all that [ __ ] that's great
it is something like were that what are
they doing yeah it's like I don't get a
sense for what the investigation part is
gonna be like and then everything is at
11 in this in this trailer it's like
okay cuz in the beginning I was like
okay this could kind of be cool baby but
then once they hit a level it's like
okay it's getting surprisingly gritty
but then all the sudden terms of like
but he's sobbing over his wife because
he loves her so much and then it becomes
like all right now we're cool yeah I'm
like everything is so huge that doesn't
seem like it seems like a cartoon yeah
doesn't know I feel like they don't know
what it wants to be it feels like
somebody saw 21 Jump Street and tried to
cram lethal weapon into much as you say
as much as you guys are gonna be out
there and say it's just a trailer yeah
yeah sure sure there's always that
however we tend to be right with these
things and again we're not saying the
show is gonna be that because hey maybe
the show in in a full-length format
makes a lot more sense
pretty much everything we've seen here
there's a lot less stuff we were psyched
about than we weren't and they sound
like it's just a thing on a like tweak a
few things and don't call it lethal
weapon and you got a brand new show
you're fine yeah totally like you don't
[ __ ] eat it just like try to like
keep lethal weapon in you're just like
can a few things that are too lethal
weapon' like then you got the [ __ ]
new show you don't have to make a lethal
weapon it's a such a marketing show
that's why yeah it's a marketing show
like oh [ __ ] my perception of this has
changed over time because I I do really
like it when people if you're gonna
remake something or you're gonna tape do
a new take on a property I like when
people get weird and change it like I'm
one of those guys but I've learned over
time and this is a good example of that
if you're gonna invite it upon yourself
because lots of script especially for
action wants the scripts get sucked in
and then turned into that property so I
feel like if you're gonna do that you
you do invite people to compare it to
the original one at least a little bit
and when the spirit is off yeah and it
feels like the spirit is off here you
know and that's that's tough man anyway
guys uh yeah thanks for tuning in for
this delightful video I knew that she
has a major bummer if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe today become a
reject I'm sure you will love you guys
off my nose
John is funny and he has a reason to GRE
on here and he is a witty writer and he
has blue house comm which she's a social
media manager of he is really on top of
that follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter and vine vine every shines a
long time let's use vine bless you
tonight we're gonna
what should might be about comment below